alrighty we are looking at a beautiful
sunrise this morning check it out we've
got some clouds off to the east but
really off to the west we've got
perfectly clear skies temps in the mid
to upper 50s out on the west side in the
middle of town we're still right around
60 degrees still in the mid 60s around
green valley 58 at sunrise mountain
henderson at 60 in seven hills at 57 low
50s out at red rock this morning we're
on our way to near 80 degrees to finish
march today it is going to be a
beautiful day now we'll still see some
of those high clouds kind of coming and
going i'll show you in a minute the
system that they're associated with mid
70s is normal but we're
a little bit above that sunrise was 6 28
sunset at 7 02. we're not going to set
any new records in the eight day
forecast but we will kind of get close
to them maybe next week we still have
winter snow in the great lakes the upper
midwest and through the plains states
just a little bit but boy springtime
thunderstorms just walloped the south
over yesterday the course of yesterday
over 200 reports of severe weather and
two dozen reports of tornadoes this line
of thunderstorms is sliding off to the
southeast you can see through the
carolinas down into northern florida and
southern georgia even atlanta's had some
rain but they seem to be out of out of
the woods now thank goodness back into
the west high pressure will start
rebuilding with a ridge as we head into
the weekend this is the system that's
dragging those high clouds into our area
occasionally
very light showers over into utah 53 for
the mountain today mostly sunny with
some northwesterly breezes while some
southerly breezes for the valley will
take over today but they shouldn't be
too strong again we'll look for highs a
little bit above normal today slide into
the 80s for april fool's day tomorrow
and then no fooling we're going to stick
to the 80s all the way through the first
week of april more clouds around on
sunday if you have outdoor plans and the
next week tuesday looks pretty warm at
near 90 degrees just for a day